vaughn has a lot going on in her life
and i'm sure has tons of opportunities
and
i don't i mean i can't wait to watch
this show new series on september 20th
on prime video called the pack november
20th would i say i said a different name
all 10 episodes are going to be
available
coming up this friday um it features 12
teams of dogs and they're humans on an
epic adventure across multiple
continents
and she co-hosts the show with lucy her
dog
lindsey vaughn here on the rich high
show how are you lindsay
hey rich i'm good how are you this is
awesome this is great
look at you with dogs i mean this is the
absolute greatest how did this how did
this one come about for you
lindsey this show um well
actually amazon contacted me and similar
to what you just said
they're like do you want to host a show
with your dog lucy
and other dogs and i'm like yes
i do it was pretty much the perfect
scenario for me
um and i was just
you know excited to be able to have a
new challenge after
my skiing career and it was perfect
timing and
you know obviously lucy loves to travel
she's been around the world with me
she's been to korea at the olympics and
so just was pretty much the perfect
scenario what type of dog is lucy
where is she the king charles cavalier
also
a stray diva what do you mean
what do you mean by that um
when we walk into an airplane like the
first first-class state she sees like
that's first heat
like no lucy like we're a little bit
farther back
um she on the show for example
she had like three people taking care of
her
she literally had someone like with a
fan someone with her food
someone carrying her and i'm like you
guys like i can't go back to real life
after this
like lucy is not going to accept
anything but
the highest standard so i'm you're
screwing me here so you're not aware
lindsay that that that lucy had a rider
in her contract that this is all uh this
is all mandated contractually this sort
of behavior is
it's it's actually her she actually does
have a writer and it says that
like she needs to have like first class
travel it's hilarious
the whole thing
it's too funny but um yeah again she's
she was a diva before this show and now
you know it's going to be difficult to
keep her
little paws on the ground after this oh
how many takes did she
did she need multiple takes to do some
scenes lindsay or how how did she how
was she to work with
professionally sometimes she was snoring
so you know that obviously killed the
vibe
um but most of the time she just
she likes being the center of attention
so anytime the camera is actually
on she perks up and is like you know
ready to go
so she's pretty perfect i mean i
should be careful because she's gonna
take my job here pretty soon look out
lindsey vonn here on the rich eyes and
show what is the show what is the
competition
uh actually about uh in the show it's a
global composition show so we travel
around the world
and in each country the dogs and their
partners have
different challenges um and it's pretty
incredible because
you know some of the dogs are well
actually all of them are just you know
normal dogs that you know
a family with kids has you know a
duchess is a black lab and
just your typical black lab but you know
they're put in these situations and
they're
you know they had a three-month
orientation and they can do some pretty
incredible things and
i can tell you for 100 certainty that
lucy and i would have failed
miserably at all of these challenges um
but the dogs on on the show
are truly incredible and you know at
every every different uh
every different country we had different
challenges and
you know i i thought that you know the
dogs couldn't get smarter but
um i was wrong every time they improved
and it was cool to see i love it looks
like a lot of rescues too
uh part of the crew here yes yeah i love
that there were a lot and
we also had a huge charity component in
each country
we donated medical supplies or money or
infrastructure
to different charitable organizations so
that was a big thing for me and i think
one of the most rewarding parts
of the show was was that and then also
the the winner gives 250 000
to the charity of their choice so pretty
pretty amazing
uh show um from the charity perspective
and it premieres this friday all tennis
total ten episodes will be available
this friday the amazon original series
the pack um
right here on the rich eisen show um so
when was the last time you were on a
on on skis at all like recreationally or
anything
how often do you do that actually for
the show
we went to switzerland okay that was the
last time i was on skis but
you know i it's still pretty painful
you know i haven't really found a way to
ski without pain yet i kind of thought
after i retired it would be a little bit
easier but
uh it's not so um i'm just kind of
looking to ski with my family this year
maybe get a couple days in and hopefully
it's not as bad
but um i'm not going to be there's not
going to be no comebacks anytime soon
that's for sure no
my my my wife has been trying to get me
on skis for years because my kids have
been skiing since pretty much birth my
wife is expert at it she's terrific at
it like she can
she can take videos she can take videos
of my kids skiing backwards you know
what i'm saying
and and and here i am on that i'll be
honest here i am at age 51 i'm i i have
trouble stopping
lindsay you know i mean i have trouble
like you know i'm doing the pizza right
down the mountain
um you know why do you need to stop
well it just it does seem to me uh when
you're down
heading towards the bottom of the
mountain um you know at some point there
must be some
stopping and
eventually yes you're right i might have
actually told you this when we were
uh in a break during some of the uh
shooting for shark week as we were
sitting together
a couple of years ago uh shooting some
of that shark week stuff
i'm i'm better at the apres ski much
much better
yeah you know you know i'm really
getting the swing of that as well
i think that's a a much better route to
take for both of us
so what what is your what is your app
race ski of choice
what is that um hot toddies are great
um okay you know it's always going to
brighten your day no matter what you're
cold i'm always cold so
you know and i hate the cold so that's
the really the perfect
perfect drink no you're not of choice
for me do i hear you but what if
see um i don't ever go outside so
um i go straight for the smoothie to
start um i'll be very honest
and then uh and then i do the red wine i
go right to the red wine because it's
five o'clock somewhere
that's pretty much what i do but you
should have glue vine instead the red
you know the red wine will put you make
you tired so i i'd go the glue vine at
least to keep you warm
okay go for the go for the what oh the
hot wine
i've never i've never i've never heard
this it's like it's it's a european uh
drink and i don't know if they have it
in the us i guess they should
but it's basically a hot wine and they
put like a little bit of
like sugar and spice to it and
everyone in europe has it all winter
long it's
probably the best thing ever made oh my
gosh um but
yeah you can make it if you go online
you can definitely find out how to make
it
just heat up heat it up put some i think
it's like orange slice in it and
some sugar and spice and everything nice
my oprah ski game look at this i got to
go on vacation
i don't know what the hell i'm going to
do okay
i will do that um one last thing too is
uh
when when people ask you to take a
selfie um
uh did do do you remember any of them if
somebody tells you you know hey we took
a selfie are you just uh kind about it i
mean what what's yours what's your
the reason why i ask you is uh my my uh
audio executive sound engineer here has
taken a selfie with you would you
remember
um if the circumstances were brought up
lindsay or no um
i can't say i don't know i probably if i
saw his face i probably remember
remember him but i mean it's kind of
like i remember
specific moments like you know when i
was a kid like meeting peek-a-boo street
or like if i um
you know i'm doing something major
otherwise
you know it's a crowd of people i'm
doing selfies probably not all right so
uh it was uh the la coliseum rams game
when was this mike
first year of the rams first game yeah
about three years ago yeah i do remember
well done lindsay's just i actually do
she's a member of society she knows she
knows how to handle these i only took
like one picture that day and it was
with him so
you remember mike that's a good job very
special
actually we do have somebody on the show
who knows you very well uh
tj jefferson is our social media grand
maester t.j
say hello to your friend what up hobie
tj
what's up homie how you been oh i'm life
is good i can't complain
you know you know i i was thinking about
lindsay and
one of the things about her yes just to
show you the incredible athlete she is
yes
back in like 2012 yeah the heat thunder
nba finals she would have people over to
her house in hollywood to
watch the games i would stop over watch
the games with her
and the one thing i remember is she had
a stationary bike in her living room and
she would start riding the bike
at tip off and she would ride this bike
for 48 minutes
of basketball hour and a half real time
right and i would just sit there and
watch her i'm like
that's what it takes to become an
olympian right is this true like
just on the bike straight through the
whole games
i mean you got to be committed you know
um but i also was committed to watching
the basketball games
you know it's a two-for-one deal it was
great how are you doing
well yes i definitely spent many hours
on the bike and tj can attach to that
yes sir yes you guys go way back you're
tj
lindsay tj is i call him and this is the
ultimate respect the forest gump
of this show like he literally has met
everybody
he is floating through life he's
literally met everybody
every single person oh yeah and you're
one of them 100
that's very accurate i've known him for
a long time he just
he he's always around you know it's like
jay's always there he knows everybody he
knows everything
it's kind of unbelievable to be honest
with you really quick how we actually
met i had a few friends that met her as
a
kentucky derby one year my buddy luke
and lindsey came to this bar la poo bell
i was hanging out with sure introduces
me to lindsay and then luke's like well
i gotta go meet my girlfriend but this
is tj he's cool and he leaves us there
and me and her just start chopping it up
at la poo belle
and that's how lindsay and i became
friends because her friend left her
i mean it's a good thing you were a nice
guy tj because that could have been a
really bad night
yeah this is true this is true hey
lindsey it's great to talk with you
um and congrats on this i can't wait to
see it
coming out on friday uh you and some
dogs and
the globe and and raising money for
charity and seeing a fun competition
involving dogs
um awesome thank you for the call
thanks switch appreciate it good to talk
to you tj you too lynch okay that's
lindsey vaughn at lindsey vaughn on
twitter and instagram right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here